all right so yes i know there is a lot
going on
um but what i can see here is that um i
i've done all my differentiating um on
the right hand side
here and what i want to do is i'm
somewhat like how i did in my informal
proof right
i see that there are real and imaginary
parts kind of uh tucked away in here
and i can also identify the real and
imaginary parts over here from the way
that i defined this function right from
the outset
okay so i'll get to that in a second but
let's try and um sift out this thing
because it's so much of a mess
i think that i can uh even though it's
going to become illegible i'm going to
file that away over here we'll do just
in case we need to refer to it again
in order to separate the real and
imaginary parts on the right hand side
even though it's kind of something which
i'm nervous about i'm clearly going to
have to expand
all these terms here right you can see
um there's an i term in here
and there's an i term in here and to get
them together i'm going to break them
out of these brackets okay so let's have
a go with this
here comes cos t dm on
dx so you can see where i got those bits
there
plus i sine t dm
on dx the next thing that comes in
i'm now expanding the second set of
brackets here is going to be
m times minus sine t times dt on dx so
i'll bring that minus sign out the front
and then i get
m sine t dt on dx
and then plus i
m cos t dt
on dx okay now you can see where i'm
going to be headed shortly
i'm going to have these imaginary parts
over here
they're going to get together and i also
want to get this on the left hand side
there's
real and imaginary parts in there as
well so
let's try and push this over a little
bit to the right hand side so i've got a
bit of space
i will highlight let's see here this is
a real
part here and this is a real part here
and then here are the imaginary parts
okay so let's do the real parts first
they're going to be
uh cos t dm on dx
minus m sine t
dt on dx okay there is
the real part and then here comes the
imaginary part we'll factor out that i
and then big set of brackets first comes
in this guy here so it's sine t
dm on dx plus
this other one we get on this side so
that's going to be
a lot of terms here m cos t dt
on dx all right there we go so i have
all of my real and imaginary parts
separated out now i'm ready to return to
my left hand
side you can see this e to the ix right
we define that right from the start as m
cos t
plus i sine t right so it's like some
complex number somewhere so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to substitute
that for
this part here so i have that eye
hanging out the front there so you can
see
where i got that from that comes from
here
and now this part is going to come in
here so
what did we say it was m outside of
cos t plus i sine
t all right now you can see on the left
hand side i need to do a little bit more
work to get the real and imaginary parts
properly separate because
this eye is going to interact with all
that stuff on the inside so what am i
going to get
well i notice we've got let's see here
in fact you know what i'm going to do it
like so
the real parts are going to come from
here and here right so
you've got i might as well keep keep
with purple so i've got the i
squared so that's negative 1 and then
i've got m
sine t okay so you can see
where i got that from i times i gives
the the negative
m and that's there and then the sine t
hanging out on the end
and then i've got plus you can see for
the
imaginary part there's going to be an i
and an m and then the cos
t i m cos
t equals and then everything on the
right hand side that has not changed
i'm so daisy that was not what i meant
to do let's duplicate that
okay so if you're following so far well
done pause and go back if you need to uh
check where you're going because i know
i
am having trouble keeping so much of
this stuff in my brain my working memory
is absolutely being maxed out
now what i've done is i've gotten the
left hand side and the right hand side
with the real and imaginary parts
separated out so it's very nice
and neat and what i'm going to do
therefore is compare the real
and imaginary parts and see what i can
gain from that now one of the things
that
you can actually prove for yourself
later on is that
if you have a look at the real or the
imaginary parts they actually end up
giving you the same amount of
information so i'm just gonna do one of
them and i will leave it as an exercise
to the reader
um to go and do the other one and
contain yourself that you actually end
up with the same results they don't
contradict
but for now let's just have a look at
the real parts okay so equating
the real parts so
on the left hand side
i've got minus m sine
t i'm actually going to move that over
to the right a little bit because i'm
going to need a bit more space you'll
see why in a second
and what do i get from the real part of
the right hand side
it's this guy here that's the real part
so let's duplicate that down
we don't need to be orange anymore okay
now
uh what have i got here well um you can
see that
um i've got uh all this mess over here
and
and some neat stuff over here now you
see how we just took the real parts
from both sides and if you wanted and i
love you to do this the imaginary parts
from
the right hand side and left hand side i
actually can do the same thing
with the sines and the cosines you can
see i've got a sine term here and a sine
term here
and then i've got a cos term here but
there's nothing over here for cos
which is to say there are zero cos
terms right so um what you've got here
is it's
almost like a simultaneous equations
sort of situation you've got some some
a's and some b's and some a's and b's
you want to compare them together or
eliminate or substitute right so i can
do the same thing
one more time just like i equated the
real parts i'm going to equate the
trigonometric parts right so i've got a
lot of colors happening here but
here are the cos terms on the left hand
side and here are the cos terms
on the right hand side and then i've got
sine terms on the left and i've got sine
terms
on the right okay so what can i get from
this well let's do the
let's do the cos terms first so what i'm
getting is
you can see how many cos ts are there
here zero of them and how many cos terms
t
cos t terms are there over here dm on dx
of them so what i get from that is
i might put these like so so you can see
it extra clear
i've got cos t's
dm on dx of them equals zero
so you can see that's how many quas t's
i have here that's how many cos t's i
have there
we'll return to that d in a second let's
do the scientists as well just to
complete things so i've got one over
here and then i've got one
over here how many sine t's do i have
on the right hand side i've got minus m
dt on dx of them and then i've got minus
m on the of them on the left hand side
okay so
you're following so far i know it looks
weird what can i do with these right
well here is where i'm now going to move
into this idea of integration or
anti-differentiation so i'm not going to
assume you know too much here i just
want you to think about
there is a function that you know that
if you were to differentiate at some
function m
if you differentiated m you should get
zero so
a gradient of zero is um that's a
horizontal line that's a flat line right
so therefore the function m that has a
derivative of 0
is just some constant it could be m
equals
5 that would be a horizontal line its
gradient would be 0 it could be m
equals negative 1 or m equals pi
anything like that right
what i'm saying is it is a constant of
some kind i don't know what constant
so what i'm going to say is m equals
i'm going to call it c 1 where c
1 is some some constant real number okay
so i might just write that
c1 is a real number okay so
um i've worked out the m and just going
all the way back up the top right
m was this unknown function here right
and i was going to
wonder like how would it change as x
changes and what i've just determined is
that apparently m doesn't change it's
some number
that has a constant value and i just
have to find out what that constant
value is so we'll do that in a second
now i'm going to turn my i to t right
i'm trying to find out what this
function is
so what do i get from this well you can
see here
i've got a minus m and a minus m over
here which i can just divide
through so that leaves me with dt on
dx equals 1.
so again i'm thinking of a function that
when you differentiate it here you got
zero
what function do you differentiate when
you differentiate it you get
one so i'm trying to anti-differentiate
here or
integrate in this context i want you to
think about this right so this is not
going to be a horizontal line but it
will still be a line right it'll be a
line
with a gradient of 1.
in other words it's going to be x
but the line x is not the only line
which has a gradient of 1. there's
an infinite number of them just like
over here you could have a constant a
different constant here would still
differentiate to zero
i could have x plus some other constant
like x plus five
or x plus a hundred or x minus a million
all of them
would differentiate and give you one so
what we're going to add on the end here
this is why you can see i had a c1 there
sneaky i didn't explain it
there's going to be another constant
hanging around here right and it's going
to be some other real number
and we call this the constant of
integration because it comes from this
process
called integration so even though i've
made some progress i've worked out that
m
is a constant function i don't know what
constant function i've worked out that t
is x plus something but i don't know
what that something is either so i have
to find out
what these two values are and we're
getting really close to the end right
here right